The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to
lecture number 11.
In this lecture, I would like
to continue discussing with
you the solution of the dynamic
equilibrium equations.
We discussed the solution of
dynamic equilibrium equations
already in lecture number 10.
In that lecture, we consider
direct integration methods.
In this lecture, I would like to
consider with you, discuss
with you the mode superposition
analysis.
The basic idea in the mode
superposition analysis is the
transformation from the U
displacements into a set of
new displacements, X.
P is an n by n matrix,
which is nonsingular.
If P is nonsingular, we should
recognize that the vector U of
lengths n is uniquely given
when we have the vector X,
also of lengths n
and vice versa.
In other words, if we have the
vector X, we can calculate U.
Or if we have U, we can
calculate X. P, of course, has
to be a nonsingular matrix.
We call this a transformation
matrix.
And we call the X displacement,
that I will be
talking about, the generalized
displacement.
Now, if we use this
transformation, we find that
if we substitute this
transformation into this
equation for U, and we postulate
that P shall not be
a function of time.
So that when we find the
derivative of U,
with respect to time--
let me denote it
by a dot here--
we simply obtain that U dot
is equal to P times X dot.
And similarly, U double dot is
equal to P times X double dot.
If we then substitute for U,
U dot, and U double dot--
in other words, for the
displacements, velocities, and
accelerations--
into this equation, we obtain
this equation, provided--
and now, there's one
additional step--
after the substitution for the
displacements, velocities, and
accelerations, we also
premultiply the total equation
by a P transposed.
In other words, what we do is
we take a P transposed here,
and we are substituting for
these vectors here from that
relation here.
The P transposed, of course,
gives us, also, a P transposed
R on the right-hand side.
So R curl here is defined
as shown down here.
Notice that M curl, C
curl, and K curl are
given as shown here.
And they involve, of course,
the M, C, and K matrices.
And this P here comes via this
substitution into these vectors.
This P transposed comes from
that P transposed here.
Now, what have we been
doing so far?
Basically, what we have
been doing is we
have changed bases.
We have come from the
displacement defined by the
finite elements--
by the finite element
nodal points--
to generalized displacements.
The generalized displacements
now govern the equilibrium of
the system.
Now, this transformation is
effective if we find that our
M curl, C curl, and K curl have
a better structure than
the matrices, M, C, and K.
And, of course, if it is
simpler to find the P matrix
or a P matrix.
Let's look at a very
simple case.
If, for example, M curl, C curl,
and K curl would all be
diagonal matrices, then the
solution of this set of
equations would be
very simple.
In fact, this is
our objective.
It is our objective to come up
with a P matrix, which when
used in this transformation,
gives us an M curl, C curl,
and K curl matrix that
are all diagonal.
And, of course, in addition we
want to find the P matrix with
a minimum amount of effort.
Once we have diagonal matrices
here on the left-hand side--
in other words, M curl,
C curl, and K curl--
then, we can use our direct time
integration schemes, the
Newmark method, or the essential
difference method.
Usually we use the
Newmark method.
Or we might even be able to
solve the decoupled equations.
They're decoupled because M
curl, CK curl, are diagonal.
We might even solve these
equations in closed form.
The question then is how do we
find P or [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
P?
We want to find it cheaply.
It shall be economical to
calculate P. And we want to,
of course, have that M curl,
C curl, K curl are ideally
diagonal matrices.
Well, the P matrix can
be constructed--
or a P matrix can be
constructed, effectively, by
looking at the free vibration
equilibrium
equations of the system.
If we look at these equilibrium
equations here, in
which we neglect damping and we
neglect the right-hand side
forces-- we're looking at the
equilibrium equations of the
dynamic system without damping
and without forces applied.
And if we look for a solution
to this system, then, we can
assume a solution
of this form.
U, of course, being our
displacement vector.
Phi being all the vector that
is independent now of time.
And here is the time dependency,
sin, omega, omega
is a radiant per second
circular frequency.
t, of course, being the time.
And t 0 is a time shift.
If we make this assumption,
substitute into here--
when we do substitute, of
course, remember we have to
take the second derivative of
this function here with
respect to time because we're
taking the second
derivative of U here.
And that gives us a minus omega
squared sin, omega t
minus t 0, substituting
from here into there.
We immediately get this equation
because we can cancel
out sin omega t minus
t 0 on both sides.
This is the resulting
equation.
So what we now want
is to solve for
phi and omega squared.
This is the generalized
eigenvalue problem.
The generalized eigenvalue
problem because M is a matrix
other than the identity
matrix in general.
And we know that they are n
solutions to this problem if K
and M are n by n matrices.
There are n solutions
to this problem.
We call these solutions
the eigensolutions.
And we call omega 1 squared,
I should say, and phi 1 the
first eigenpair.
This is the second eigenpair,
this is the nth eigenpair.
There are n such eigenpairs.
Each of these eigenpairs
satisfies this equation here.
Therefore, these are
a solution--
we call it an eigensolution--
to this equation.
And in addition, we also can
prove-- we can show--
that the phi I vectors--
these vectors here--
are M orthogonal.
M orthogonal because phi
I transposed M phi j--
for example, phi 1 transposed
M phi 2 is equal to 0.
And phi 1 transposed M phi j--
sorry phi 1 transposed M
phi 1 is equal to 1.
And because it's equal to 1,
they're not only M orthogonal,
they're indeed even
M ortho normal.
What we find is that if we look
at this eigenproblem, and
we notice that a certain
vector satisfies this
eigenproblem, then also a
multiple of that vector
satisfies the eigenproblem.
And we determine this constant,
this undetermined
constant, in such a way as to
have phi I transposed M phi I
equal to 1.
So these are the eigenpairs and
the eigenvectors, phi 1 to
phi n, satisfy this relation.
The eigenvalues, omega 1 squared
to omega n squared can
be ordered in this way where
we find that we might have
multiple eigenvalues.
Omega 1 might be equal
to omega 2.
But if we do, we still have only
a total number of n such
eigenvalues.
I will discuss in the next
lecture with you the solution
techniques that we're using to
calculate these eigenpairs.
Let's for the moment assume that
we have calculated them.
And we want to use them.
Well, if we now define
the following
matrix, phi capital phi.
It's a capital phi because
we see crossbars
top and bottom here.
If we define this matrix
as phi 1 to phi n--
in other words, we're taking
the first eigenvector, and
list it as a first column
of this matrix here.
The second eigenvector, we list
as the second column in
this matrix and so on.
So that we find, of course, that
this matrix here is an n
by n matrix.
And if we define a diagonal
matrix, omega squared.
This is a capital omega.
Omega squared, being
equal to 0s in the
off diagonal elements.
But the diagonal elements
being omega 1
squared to omega n squared.
Then, we can write the solutions
to the eigenproblem.
The solutions to the
eigenproblem--
and I'm still talking
about this
eigenproblem problem here.
We can write the solutions to
this e eigenproblem in the
following form.
Notice that this omega squared
here has to be on the back of
the capital phi.
In other words, this is the
solution to the problem, K phi
equals omega squared M phi,
where the omega squared is a
scalar and appears
here in front.
We usually write it in front.
Of course, we can put
it also at the back
because it's a scalar.
We can put in front
or the back.
However, when we have listed the
solutions to this problem
in this way, then, we have to
put the capital omega squared
at the back of M times phi.
You can verify that by simply
multiplying out
the right-hand side.
We also have this relationship
here, which is the M ortho
normality, the phi ortho
normality with M. In other
words, this here says nothing
else and phi I transposed M
phi j is equal to delta I j.
We call this the
chronica delta.
And this chronica delta
is equal to 1 for I
being equal to j.
And it's 0 otherwise.
So we are having this
relationship here.
And if we use this relationship,
and we are
premultiplying this equation by
phi transposed to capital
phi transposed now,
both sides.
We are finding that we
are getting here
the identity matrix.
And therefore, we're having that
this left-hand side is
equal to omega squared.
This matrix here.
And this is an important fact.
In other words, we find
that the vectors--
the eigenvectors--
satisfy these two
relationships.
Now, if we look back at what
we started off with in our
multiple position analysis
discussion, we wanted a matrix
that we call P, which is such
that P transposed M, P ideally
is a diagonal matrix.
Well, we have no
such a matrix.
If we take phi being equal to P.
Then, phi transposed M phi
is in fact a diagonal matrix.
In fact, a very nice diagonal
matrix, the identity matrix,
which is a matrix that
is diagonal.
It has just once on
the diagonal.
Similarly, we wondered here
that P transposed KP is a
diagonal matrix.
Well, we have achieved that
by this phi matrix.
So the phi matrix is, indeed,
a particular P
matrix that we can use.
So what we are then saying is
let us use a multiple position
analysis this particular
P matrix.
The P matrix, which is equal
to the phi matrix and phi
storing the eigenvectors of the
generalized eigenproblem.
Well, substituting from here, as
before, into the governing
dynamic equilibrium
equations, we
directly obtain this equation.
However, we notice now that this
matrix here, in general,
is not yet a diagonal matrix.
We call that our C curl.
And our C curl has not been
diagonalized yet.
We will have to deal with that
matrix still a little later.
How do we solve these
equations?
Well, if we solve these
equations, we have to also
recognize, of course, that we
have to include the initial
conditions to the problem.
And the initial conditions
mean that the initial
displacements are defined
and the initial
velocities are defined.
These, of course, are the
initial conditions that are
used in the direct integration
solution of the governing
dynamic equilibrium equations.
Well, if we are now performing
the solution of this set of
equations, we will have to
transform these initial
conditions to initial conditions
on the generalized
displacements.
And that is achieved via
these relations here.
Let us see how we
derive these.
Well, if we look at this
equation here, and if we
notice that, of course,
this equation must be
applicable 4 times 0.
We can simply put a 0 there.
And we put a 0 there.
Then, of course, we also
recognize that we can
premultiply this equation
with this relation here.
And if we do that on the
right-hand side, we notice
that phi transposed M
times that phi is
the identity matrix.
And so we have this relation
directly obtained.
The left-hand side in this
equation is the right-hand
side in this equation.
And the right-hand side here
is simply this 0 x now.
The same holds also for
the initial velocity.
We can simply put dots on top
of the U here and of the X.
And therefore, we have
this relation here.
So the solution of this set of
equations and with these
initial conditions subject to
these initial conditions,
gives us a solution to of
the dynamic response.
Now, I should mention here that
we still have to deal
with the damping matrix.
The damping matrix here needs
particular attention.
We do not have, in general,
a diagonal matrix here.
And we will want to construct
specific damping matrices with
which we can deal,
effectively.
And yet, of course, these
matrices must make,
physically, sense.
Let us look now, however, first
at the case where we
neglect damping.
When we neglect damping, we have
this set of equations and
individual equations
of this form.
Notice that these are individual
equations because
this is a vector.
This is a diagonal matrix.
And on the right-hand side, we
simply have a vector off load,
of course, time dependent.
So we can look at the first row
in this matrix relation.
And the first row in that matrix
relation will be this
equation here with
I equal to 1.
The I-th row in this relation
here is the
I-th equation here.
In other words, I subscripts
on the [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
And, in general therefore,
we want to
solve n such equations.
I going from 1 to n, with this
being the load vector and, of
course, with the initial
conditions.
These initial conditions are
obtained by simply looking at
this equation here and
extracting the I-th row from
each of these two relations.
So this is then the problem.
Notice the following that if we
solve all n equations with
these initial conditions, then,
if we use, for example,
the Newmark direct integration
method on these equations, we
would obtain exactly the same
solution as if we had solved
the fully coupled equations.
The fully coupled equations--
let me write them down once
more here--
plus KU equals R.
In other words, whether we
apply the Newmark time
integration scheme, a direct
integration scheme, to this
set of equations with the
initial conditions on U and U
dot or apply the Newmark direct
time integration scheme
to this set of equations, or
rather this one here with
these initial conditions, we
obtain exactly the same
response provided we use the
same time step, delta t in
both integrations.
There has been no assumption
so far.
All we have done is a
transformation from the U
displacements to the
X displacements.
And this transformation is
effective if we can find the
phi matrix that we're using
in the transformation very
cheaply, very economically.
Well, the effectiveness, really,
of multiple position
goes beyond what I have
just described.
The important point in multiple
position analysis is
that we do not need to solve
all of these equations.
That we do not need to solve
and look at all of the
decoupled equations.
But let us look first once also
at how we can solve the
decoupled equations
now exactly.
Where we can solve them exactly
for example using a
Duhamel integral formulation
as shown here.
X i of t is given via
this relation here.
And we would, of course,
substitute our ri of tau where
we now assume that this part
here is given, directly.
In a computer program, very
frequently r i would only be
given as a segment of
straight lines.
And if that is the case, then,
of course, we might have to
still evaluate all of this
here numerically if the
segment is very complicated,
complex, like
an earthquake analysis.
ri might be varying
very rapidly.
And then, we might still want to
evaluate this, numerically.
However in general, we can
evaluate here this
relationship analytically.
And we don't need to use
numerical integration.
Having got xi, of course, we get
our U of t as shown here
by our transforming back.
Well, the important point that
I now would like to get back
to you and discuss with you for
a little while is that we
do not need to use or to solve
all of these equations in
multiple position analysis.
In fact, multiple position
analysis is only effective
when we do not need
to look at all of
these decoupled equations.
If we have to solve all
decoupled equations, then, we
would have to calculate, course,
first all eigenvalues
and eigenvectors, which can
be an enormous expense.
And then, the multiple
position analysis
would not be effective.
I would like to repeat, however,
if we do solve all
decoupled equations, using a
specific time integration
scheme with a specific
data t time step.
Then, if we use the same time
integration scheme on
decoupled equations with the
same time step, we must get
exactly the same response.
Then there has been no
assumption so far.
Well, however, if we then
do neglect some of
the equations here.
We do not solve some
of the equations.
Then, of course, our response
will be different that we are
predicting via this approach
when we compare with the
response predicted by solving
these equations.
Well, let us look once at this
graph again, which we already
looked at briefly in
the last lecture.
And I would like to explain
to you now why it is not
necessary to solve all of the
decoupled equations in
multiple position analysis.
Why it is not, in general,
not necessary?
Well, if we look at a
single oscillator
equation, as given here.
I include a damp in here,
of course, side
can be equal to 0.
Where P is the driving
frequency, omega is the
frequency of the oscillator
itself.
And if we plot the maximum
dynamic response observed,
which we define if the dynamic
load factor when we divide
that maximum dynamic response by
the static response, we get
this set of curves.
Let us look at say the curved
side equal to 0
a little bit closer.
If we do that, and if we
solve this equation
with side equals 0.
This term now not being there.
For certain values of P over
omega, we are getting this
curve here and that
curve here.
What do we notice?
Well, we notice that when P over
omega is equal to 0, we
are getting the static
response.
Or P over omega very
small, we're
getting the static response.
This means, of course, that
omega, the system frequency,
is much larger than the applied
frequency, which means
really that this oscillator
is extremely stiff.
Well, when compared to the
frequency of load application.
So then, we are in this range.
And we notice that say P over
omega in this range here,
smaller than a certain value,
and this is here 0.5 say,
smaller than 0.2.
We would see that basically, the
maximum dynamic response
is really just nothing else
than the static response.
So we are talking in this
region here really about
static response.
And in this region here, we
are talking about a truly
dynamic response.
Now what does that mean?
Well, if we look at our
decoupled equations here, it
means that if i consist of
frequencies, basically, which
when measured on the system of
the oscillator frequency are
very small, we, basically, would
have a static solution.
You would, basically, have a
static solution for this
equilibrium equation.
A truly dynamic solution will
only be obtained when P, in
other words, the frequency of
the load divided by omega,
falls into this range here.
Well, this is what we
are using in most
superposition analysis.
We only need to consider those
frequencies of the system.
And these are the frequencies
of the systems, the omegas,
which are truly excited
by the dynamic loads.
We only need to look at those
decoupled equilibrium
equations for which we have that
the frequencies in the
decoupled equations are truly
excited by the dynamic loads.
Now, I only talked about
the P value here.
Of course, in an actual
analysis, we would find that
ri of P contains a number of
frequencies, a spectrum of
frequencies.
Well, what we have to do is look
at the highest frequency
that is contained in ri.
And we measure that highest
frequency on the frequencies
of the system.
If that highest frequency
divided by the frequency of
the system is falling into
this range here, we are
talking about a static
response, basically.
And we do not need to consider
those equilibrium equations in
are multiple position
analysis.
Well, so what we are then saying
is let us all solve
these equations not from i
equals 1 to n but from i
equals 1 to P. And then, instead
of obtaining the true
response, the "exact" response,
we are obtaining a
response U P. i equals 1 to P.
Phi i, x i gives us U P, where
U P is an approximation now
to the U displacements.
And the U displacements, once
again, are the solution to
this system of equations.
How can we find out the error?
Well, if U P is an approximate
solution to the system of
equations that we want to solve,
then, let us substitute
back into that system
of equations.
Let me write it down
once more here.
We have MU double dot
plus KU equals R
that we want to solve.
Well, we can also write that, of
course, MU double dot plus
KU minus R. And this
shall be 0.
So if we have an approximate
solution to this set of
equations, why not just
substitute that approximate
solution in here and see how
large the right-hand side is.
If it's exactly 0, well, then
we have that our U P is,
indeed, very close to U. And if
it's exactly 0 because U P
would be equal to U.
We will not find this to be 0.
We will never find it to be 0
because in a computer, we
would, of course, use finite
digit arithmetic to evaluate
the left-hand side.
And we would have at
least round off.
But what we want is at the
right-hand side calculated,
which we now might call some
value shall be close to 0.
And that means really what
we want to measure
is this part here.
Now what have I written
down here?
I have here epsilon P of t
being this vector here.
This is a vector.
And we can call this an out of
balance load vector divided by
the applied load vector.
Notice that what I'm doing here,
I take the norm of this
vector because I want to
get a single number.
I want to get a single number
here, which is representative
of all the elements
in that vector.
The same applies here.
This norm is calculated by
taking each value in this
vector, squaring that value,
adding the squares of the
values up, and then, taking
a square root out
of that final value.
In other words, if we write it
down here, quickly, what we do
is if we have a vector a, and
we want to find this norm.
What we do is we take a 1
squared plus a 2 squared, et
cetera, add all the individual
entries up
of that vector here--
squares of the entries up--
and then, take the square
root out of it.
And that gives us a single
number, which is
representative of all the
elements in that vector.
Notice that if one element is
large, well then, this value
must be large, too, because
that one element will make
this value large here.
Well, if epsilon t is close to
0, assuming that r of t is not
0, of course.
Otherwise, you couldn't
use this.
You would have to use some
equivalent approach.
If epsilon P is close to 0,
then, we know that our
equilibrium equation has been
solved quite accurately.
In general, we might find that
it's not close to 0.
And what we want to do is
a static correction.
This static correction takes
into account the fact that we
have neglected the
higher modes.
And in the higher modes, of
course, we know we have
basically static response.
that's why we did not include
those equations in the
multiple position analysis.
So what do we do in that
static correction?
We recognize that R could
be written in this form.
This RI is exactly the value
that I defined earlier.
M phi i is a vector.
You see, I can take M and
multiply it by phi i, and I
get a vector.
Now they are in such
a vectors.
We might not have calculated
all n.
But you can say that indeed,
in theory there are n.
So we can write this down.
We also then can calculate the
delta R, which is that amount
of the load vector, which has
not been included in the
multiple position analysis.
How do we obtain it?
Well, we know R is the
total load vector.
And if we now sum instead of i
equals 1 to n, only from i
equals 1 to P, we are getting
this part here.
But this part is exactly what
we have included in the
multiple position analysis
already.
So we are left with a vector on
the left-hand side, which
we have not included in the
multiple position analysis.
And we did not include it
because we knew at most, we
can have static response,
corresponding to these loads.
Let us now calculate that
static response.
That's done right down here.
Now, this static response has
to be added to the response
which we predicted in the
multiple position analysis.
Let us now go to the case
with damping included.
So far we neglected that.
Now, with damping included, we
have this part here, too.
Notice phi transpose C
phi, in general, is
not a diagonal matrix.
And that's why I considered
first the
case without damping.
However, if we have
proportionate damping, and in
structural analysis, frequently,
all that is
necessary is to include
proportionate damping.
Which we postulate to
be of this form.
2 omega i xi i.
Delta ij is again the chronica
delta, which is equal to 1
when i is equal to j and is
equal to 0 otherwise.
So if we are postulating
this, where omega i,
of course, is given.
That is the free vibration
frequency, which is stored in
this matrix here.
xi i is a value, which
we are not given yet.
We have not discussed it yet.
But if we postulate that this
matrix here, basically, or
each entry in that matrix can
be written in this way.
Then, indeed, we would have
decoupled equations.
It turns out that in practice,
as I mentioned already, this
is all that is necessary to
include damping appropriately.
Well, if we know these xi i
values, then, we can also
construct a C matrix with
the xi i values given.
The xi i values are frequently
obtained from experiments.
In other words, the structure
is taken, its vibrated, it's
excited into certain
vibration modes.
And from these experiments
then, we
obtain the xi i value.
So once we have the xi
i value given, we can
calculate the C matrix.
And one way of calculating is
to use the Caughey series.
Here we have the Caughey series,
which was proposed for
calculating the C matrix, which
satisfies this criteria.
In other words, damping
is proportional.
Well, if the psi i values are
given, we can calculate the
omega i, of course
are also given.
We can calculate using this
equation, the constants a 0 to
ap minus 1.
Once we have these constants,
we can substitute them into
here and be coming up
with a C matrix.
And this C matrix here,
indeed, satisfies the
normality property shown here.
So, in other words, given the
psi i values from experimental
results, given the omega i
values, we can calculate a C
matrix that, in fact, gives us
a diagonal matrix when we
carry out phi i transposed
C phi j.
A special case of this C matrix
is Rayleigh damping,
used abundantly in practice.
Where we just include the first
two terms, alpha and
beta being constants now.
Let us go through a particular
example.
Let's say that we know the
critical damping psi 1 is 0.02
and psi 2 is 0.10.
In other words, 10% critical
damping in the second mode and
2% critical damping
in the first mode.
The corresponding frequencies
are 1 and 3.
We want to calculate
our friend, beta.
Well, what we do is use this C
matrix in the relation, phi i
transposed, C times phi i.
And that should give
us 2 omega psi i.
Of course, we have two
i values, i equals 1
and i equals 2.
So we can apply this
equation twice.
Well, when we calculate
it out, we get this.
Applying it twice, we directly
obtain these
two equations here.
And we solve these two equations
for alpha and beta.
Having alpha and beta, we can
substitute now back into this
equation here and have
our C matrix.
This would be, for example, a C
matrix that we could use in
a direct integration analysis.
You see, if we are performing a
multiple position analysis,
we might know, from experience,
from experimental
results, that psi 1 and psi
2 are of these two values.
And then, if we know that we
have so much critical damping
or so much damping in the first
and second vibration
mode, and we want to perform
a step-by-step direct
integration analysis, we would
have to construct a C matrix.
And this is the procedure
to construct a C matrix.
Then, of course, we would have
to ask ourselves well, knowing
these psi values for omega 1 and
omega 2, what are now the
psi values that we are
implicitly using for the
higher modes when we employ
this specific C matrix?
And we use now, this
equation here.
This is the equation, which we
already derived on this view
graph here by looking
at this relation.
You are now using this equation
because this equation
must be applicable not just for
psi 1 and psi 2 but for
all psi values.
Well, then using this equation,
we can solve for the
psi values.
And, of course, psi 1 and psi 2,
substituting alpha and beta
in here and omega 1 and omega
2 would, indeed, be just 2%
and 10%, 0.02 and 0.10.
However, we can now use
this equation to
get the high xi values.
And there's something to be
observed, which is quite
important, namely we notice that
the beta value that we
calculated is associated
with the high
frequencies, basically.
And the alpha value goes away.
Or this contribution goes away
when we're looking at the high
frequencies.
For high frequencies therefore,
the beta value is a
dominant factor.
And for low frequencies,
the alpha value is
the dominant factor.
In other words, once again,
looking at this equation here,
in the high frequency response,
beta K, really, will
determine the damping.
And in the low frequency, the
response is really the alpha
value that determines
the damping.
Well, the response solution
now would be performed in
exactly the same
way as before.
As in the case of
no damping, we
solve now again P equations.
P equations only.
And we are doing that by looking
at this equation and
with, of course, ri being given
as shown here and the
initial conditions
being given here.
Solving this equation here via
numerical integration or exact
integration, using, for
something, Duhamel integral,
we obtain the xi values
as a function of time.
We substitute into here to
get our U P, which is an
approximation to the
solution of the
dynamic equilibrium equations.
The dynamic equilibrium
equations now being MU double
dot plus CU dot plus KU,
being equal to r.
Notice we have a C matrix
in here now.
However, and this is an
important point, we have a
specific C matrix constructed
such that the phi i transposed
C phi j gives us a diagonal
matrix with the diagonal
elements being equal to
2 omega i, psi i.
And one of these matrices,
for example, would be
the Rayleigh matrix.
The matrix obtained using
Rayleigh damping, rather.
The important point is, once
again, that all we have been
doing so far is to make a
change of bases from the
finite element coordinates
to the generalized
displacements, xi.
That was the first step.
The second step was that we
are neglecting the modes P
plus 1 to n by only solving the
first P equations here and
using this as an approximation
to the actual solution.
The important point, of course,
is now that we have to
ask ourselves when is
multiple position
analysis really effective?
Some considerations I have here
summarized on the last
view graph.
The multiple position analysis
is effective when the response
lies in only a few modes.
What does this mean?
It means that if we look at our
eigenvalue problem, K phi
equals omega squared M phi.
We only need to solve this
eigenvalue problem
for a very few modes.
In other words, P being much
smaller than M, I will only
have to solve for phi 1 up to
phi P and omega 1 squared up
to omega P squared.
This is a very important
point.
I assumed here that we are
taking the lowest frequencies,
omega 1 to omega P. Of course,
in general analysis, it might
just be necessary to calculate
certain frequencies, say omega
10 to omega 20.
We only want to find the
frequencies in a certain range
because we know that the
excitation frequency only lies
in a particular range.
That would be, for example,
the case in vibration
excitation analysis.
This then is a requirement for
multiple position analysis,
really, to be effective.
When the response is obtained
over many time intervals, then
multiple position analysis
also becomes effective.
We should remember here that
if we perform a direct
integration analysis, and if
that is an implicit direct
integration analysis, using the
Newmark method, for example.
Then, the number of operations
that we talked about in the
Newmark method was
1/2 nm squared.
That is the initial triangular
factorization
that we have to perform.
m being the half bandwidth.
Plus 2 nm.
n is the order, of course,
of the system.
m is the half bandwidth,
once again.
Times t, the number
of time steps.
This is an initial expense that
we have to perform, using
the direct integration Newmark
method, for example.
The same holds for the
Wilson Theta method.
or the Houbolt method.
This is an initial expense.
And then, we perform this
number of operations
for each time step.
Now, if we have to run 5,000
time steps, then direct
integration would be
extremely, extremely expensive.
And, in fact, you might not be
able to afford it, using
implicit direct integration.
Well, therefore, you can see
directed by looking at this
operation column.
What should make the analysis
more effective is to bring
down the bandwidths.
And, of course, this is exactly
what we're doing in
multiple position analysis.
We are going from a bandwidth
of m to a bandwidth of 0.
You are having a diagonal
matrix.
Remember, the bandwidths we
defined to be the number of
off diagonal elements here
that we are having.
We did not include
the diagonal.
That is a half bandwidth.
If you look at the
total band here--
that total band here was
equal to 2m plus 1.
So if we are reducing the
bandwidths, as we do in
multiple position analysis, then
we can see immediately
that this number of operations
here, which is directly
proportional to the number
of times steps goes down.
And that is exactly the
objective in multiple position
analysis that I talked
about earlier.
That is the first important
objective.
We want to reduce the bandwidths
for the direct
integration analysis.
The second objective, of course,
is that we do not need
to even consider all
of the equations.
So looking at n.
We are reducing n, also.
We are not looking anymore
at n equations.
We are looking at P equations.
And we are reducing the
bandwidths as I said earlier.
m goes to 0.
And n goes to P. Of
course, this is an
approximate count here.
So basically, you can see that
in the solution using multiple
position analysis, the number
of operations in the time
integration of the decoupled
equations is
relatively small, is little.
And, in fact, this solution
here can be obtained very,
very effectively.
The time integration of the
decoupled equations is very
effective in an actual
practical analysis.
Where the expense lies in
multiple position is really in
the calculation of the required
frequencies and motions.
And, of course, this is exactly
the subject of the
next lecture where I want to
discuss with you the effective
solution techniques for
calculating these vectors and
frequencies.
Multiple position analysis is
effective, altogether only,
when we can calculate these
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
in an effective way.
I should also finally, once
again, emphasize that it may
be important to calculate the
error, epsilon pt that I
referred to.
Or to add a static correction
to the predicted response in
the multiple position analysis
when P is, of course, much
smaller than n.
We have neglected the high
frequency response here.
That high frequency response
is a static
response, in general.
And should be taken into
account via say static
correction, as I have been
discussing with you.
This is all I wanted to
say in this lecture.
Thank you very much for
your attention.